finally tonight it's Friday that means
notable quotables I just don't think I'm
in a nightmare so I'm gonna wake up one
day and I'm gonna be like everything's
gonna be normal look at me I want to be
the last father of a murdered kid the
mental health authorities failed but the
system failed federal law enforcement
failed our president failed less
tweeting here a little more listening it
didn't get a lot of play in yesterday's
kind of reality TV governance meeting
Moscow plays both arsonist and
firefighter when I said that we call for
an immediate end to these offensive
operations we mean it they do not have
an obligation to open their door ice
officials say this is the mayor and
every other politician that wants to
vilify the men and women ice we're not
going away
nothing that has taken place will affect
the valuable work that Jared is doing
the last thing I wanted to do is walk
away from one of the great honors of my
life being the Secretary of Homeland
Security but I did something I'm pretty
sure I'm not the devil
at least my wife and my mother don't
think that I am one week thanks for
inviting us into your home tonight